[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
huit questions sur l'avenir du
télétravail
vers une révolution du travail à
distance
alors qu'il ne concernait en france qu
environ 7% des actifs avant la crise le
télétravail concerne désormais un quart
des salariés
en s'appuyant sur une table ronde qui a
réuni plusieurs experts au sénat en
avril 2021 les sénateurs céline boulay
sp rogner cécile cukierman née stéphane
sautarel rapporteur au nom de la
délégation à la prospective ont formulé
un état des lieux ainsi que huit
questions sur les risques et les
bénéfices que représente la
généralisation progressive de ce nouveau
mode de travail
pour les salariés le télétravail
favorise une économie des temps et des
coûts de transport mais aussi des
déplacements polluants
la délégation estime par ailleurs qu'il
convient d'encourager dès maintenant la
réutilisation et le partage des objets
numériques pour éviter le suréquipement
des entreprises et des ménages
côté employeurs le télétravail permet
une réduction des coûts immobiliers et
une baisse de l'absentéisme
mais la dispersion géographique pose la
question du contrôle du travail des
collaborateurs et remet en question
l'organisation du travail
la délégation préconise de transformer
les modes de management pour les faire
reposer davantage sur la confiance
cela passe par un effort de formation
notamment de l'encadrement intermédiaire
le rapport de la délégation souligne que
le télétravail représente une
opportunité pour l'économie
pendant la crise sanitaire il a permis
d'éviter plus de 200 milliards d'euros
de pertes de production et a eu un
impact positif sur la productivité à
long terme
le défi est de veiller à préserver
l'attractivité résidentielle de la
france pour en faire une terre d'accueil
plutôt que d'exil des télétravailleurs
à la faveur du télétravail un mouvement
de relocalisation peut s'enclencher et
prospérer dans les années à venir au
profit d'une ruralité gagnante
la délégation préconise d'anticiper
l'arrivée de nouveautés les travailleurs
dans les territoires à travers des
investissements qui leur seraient
destinées tiers-lieux installations de
la fibre maintien de services publics
locaux infrastructures de loisirs et
lieux de sociabilité aide à la
construction de logements adaptés
de telles mesures permettraient d'éviter
à la fois la délocalisation des emplois
télétravail abl hors de france et la
délocalisation des télétravailleurs
nationaux
d'ici à 2050 le télétravail devrait
concerner 30 à 50% des actifs dans notre
pays
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport de la délégation à
la prospective
[Musique]